delicious ashhadu for the people of
Lithuania the Iron Curtain is made from
pine this their border with Russia it's
wet and inhospitable and a small band
who patrol it are worried about the
other side this summer the Lithuanians
will draw a new line in these woods when
they start building a border fence with
cameras and sensors as part of a plan to
protect the EU from the east well we are
right on the frontier Russian territory
starts here just a few metres away by
the red and green post and you know for
a lot of Lithuanians that's just too
close for comfort
the border guards they're a bit jumpy
and the entire nation is anxious to
Lithuania is mobilizing for war on the
border and in the company boardroom we
met two brothers who manufacture
electronics they've joined a volunteer
army and agreed to show us their arsenal
it's all bought with their own money and
they told me there's another 10,000 men
and women just like them you'll be
prepared to fight the Russians if you
had to yeah definitely I mean we are
prepared today as well so if it would
happen tonight we would be ready so
there's no doubt that the Russians might
say listen you know this is all it's
hysteria we are training for defending
myself so if they don't attack we have
nothing to worry about that sounds a lot
like the generals from NATO member
nations have shipped 4,000 troops to the
region with 1,000 German soldiers now
stationed in Lithuania but the conflicts
already begun it's
although it's not exactly conventional
we've obtained this anonymous email sent
to top officials alleging an attack by
German soldiers on a 15 year old
Lithuanian orphan at first German
soldiers just flirted it reads but then
surrounded and raped her the authorities
say the emails fake and when I visited
the local orphanage employees also told
me it wasn't true I think it's dangerous
piece and I think that they really
picked on the right time and the right
topping the clever way to create chaos
says the editor of the country's biggest
news site who knows plenty about cyber
war this operation is frequently
attacked by hackers and propagandists
and mysterious powders in the post I
think we all very well know who was
behind that the Kremlin is behind it and
it's we should just state it very
clearly president putin disagrees he
says the West is distorting reality
still many Lithuanians feel their
survivals at stake and at a BBQ
restaurant we found a group called the
elves fighting and fact-checking the
trolls online of course it's not evenly
matched but it's more like David and
Goliath fight you know but everyone
knows how that fight to end it so it's
all done in their spare time another
example of grassroots mobilization but I
think if we do right things
we will avoid war Lithuania is preparing
for the worst
a small nation this motivated by fear
John sparks Sky News in Vilnius